toi bonsoir le jackpot pour la nouvelle
municipalité de vichy l'exploitation du
grand casino est de nouveau autorisé
décision prise hier par pierre joxe le
ministre de l'intérieur qui en a réservé
la primeur à jean michel belorgey député
socialiste de la circonscription de
vichy claude malhuret le maire bien sûr
se réjouit de cette nouvelle
d'autant que le groupe partouche son
poulain devient le nouveau
concessionnaire on découvre les tables
on dépoussière et on recommence au grand
casino de vichy ce sera pour le 14
juillet qui pour une fois ne sera pas
bleu blanc rouge mais noir rouge perd 1
perd pas ses manques
la commission supérieure des jeux avait
émis un avis favorable la semaine
dernière suivi de la décision du
ministère de l'intérieur
le concessionnaire du casino sera donc
le groupe partouche qui possède
plusieurs établissements dans le nord de
la france et dont le responsable était
présent aujourd'hui à vichy pour mettre
au point les derniers détails pour cette
réouverture
c'est le casino qui a été fréquenté par
presque tous les grands de ce monde
une certaine époque pic a été vraiment
la ville qui recevait le plus
d'étrangers puisqu'en principe les
casinos sont faits pour les étrangers
donc la ville de vichy sans casino
je crois que c'était anormal quand on
sait que pierre joxe n'aime pas beaucoup
les casinos vous avez dû donner des
garanties sérieuses mais mon groupe si
vous voulez se compose essentiellement
d'une famille qui connut du ministère de
l'intérieur qui est connu des courses et
jeux qui rit qui supervise les casinos
nous avons nous gérons des casio depuis
maintenant 17 ans ses frères enfants et
presque bientôt les petits enfants donc
au point de vue garanties nous moral et
pécuniaires aucun problème précisons par
ailleurs que le groupe partouche est
également portée acquéreur pour l'autre
casino de vichy l'élysée palace ce qui à
terme pourrait permettre de faire un
casino d'hiver et un d'été ou de
maintenir les deux toute l'année si la
fréquentation le permet en tout cas la
rapidité avec laquelle l'autorisation a
été donnée aura permis de sauver la
saison